right when you crack the joke will was
laughing that phony ass left
and then Jada rolled her eyes a little
bit of head like you and he went
yeah that ain't funny
[Applause]
I think she put a spell on that
she had a Men In Black Voodoo Doll
underneath her chair
cause that out of nowhere
he just changed his whole up so we
saw her roll our eyes up in her head but
that ain't what she did she put a spell
on him
[Music]
and the Ghost of Tupac Shakur possessed
Will Smith's body and then he said
even the way the walked back to
the seat that wasn't Will's wall in
there that was Tupac walk
I know that duck leg walk
and definitely walk that's I work with
Tupac that is burning from Above the Rim
Nick got out the Ranger
[Applause]
that is Bishop from juice I know
that duck leg walk
look at me even the way he was screaming
from his seat all ignorant and like
Tupac on one of his disc records keep my
wife stirring out your
mind
that sound like first off East Side
about to click the claim
foreign
[Applause]